FDA JUST GIVING FULL APPROVAL
TO PFIZER’S COVID VACCINE.
THE FIRST VACCINE TO GET THE
FULL APPROVAL AND IN RECORD
TIME.
CRITICS ASKING IF THE PROCESS
WAS RUSHED.
WAS IT?
LET’S BRING IN ADMIRAL BRETT
GIROIR FORMER ASSISTANT
SECRETARY AND TESTING CZAR.
TELL US, SIR, ABOUT WHAT THIS
MOMENT MEANS TO GET FULL
APPROVAL.
>> THIS IS A VERY BIG MOMENT IN
OPERATION WARP SPEED HISTORY
AND THE HISTORY OF OUR FIGHT
AGAINST THE PANDEMIC.
PRIOR TO THIS WE HAD EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIZATION.
WHAT THAT MEANT IS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS OUTWEIGHED THE
KNOWN AND POTENTIAL HARMS.
WHAT THIS SAYS TODAY IS WE KNOW
THE BENEFITS, WE KNOW THE
HARMS, AND THIS VACCINE IS SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE AND EVERY
CONFIDENCE CAN BE GIVEN TO THAT
AND AMERICANS SHOULD FEEL VERY
GOOD, BETTER THAN THEY DID
YESTERDAY ABOUT GETTING THE
VACCINE.
>> WHAT TOOK SO LONG?
>> IT IS A COMPLICATED PROCESS.
THERE ARE MANY, MANY GOOD
PROFESSIONALS AND CREDIBLE
PROFESSIONALS AT THE FDA.
IT DOES TAKE A WHILE BECAUSE
ALL THE DATA IS LOOKED AT IN
DETAIL.
EVERY PAGE IS TURNED.
THE FACILITIES ARE INSPECTED.
HOWEVER, AGAIN AS I SAID
BEFORE, I THINK IT’S
UNCONSCIONABLE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T HAVE AN
FDA COMMISSIONER EVEN NOMINATED
TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP.
IT IS COMPLICATED.
THERE IS A LOT OF MATERIAL AND
AMERICANS SHOULD FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT IN THE PROCESS.
>> Dana: SOME SAID THEY WERE
HESITANT TO GET THE VACCINE AND
POINTED TO THE LACK OF FULL
APPROVAL.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IN ITS GOAL TO
GET MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED CAN
UTILIZE THIS NEWS?
>> WELL, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL UTILIZE THE NEWS.
THE POLL SAID 30% OF THOSE WHO
HAVEN’T BEEN VACCINATED WOULD
BECOME VACCINATED, FEEL
CONFIDENT ABOUT THAT ONCE THE
VACCINE RECEIVED FULL APPROVAL.
THAT JUST HAPPENED.
THE VACCINE IS FULLY APPROVED
AND I’M VERY HOPEFUL THIS WILL
PUSH PEOPLE OVER THE EDGE TO GO
GET THE VACCINE BECAUSE IT IS
OUR BEST PROTECTION ASIDE FROM
NATURAL IMMUNITY AGAINST ALL
THE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS
PARTICULARLY THAT DELTA IS
CAUSING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> Bill: AS YOU LOOK DOWN THE
ROAD WITH THE FDA APPROVAL
EVERY DAY ABOUT A BOOSTER SHOT
REQUIREMENT.
HOW DO YOU VIEW THAT PROCESS
TODAY?
>> SO, I BELIEVE BOOSTERS WILL
BE AUTHORIZED AT SOME POINT BY
THE FDA.
HOPEFULLY SOON.
THE DATA IN ISRAEL AND DATA
HERE ARE CLEAR THAT OUR VACCINE
IMMUNITY IS VERY GOOD BUT IT
WANES OVER TIME.
AFTER FIVE, SIX, SEVEN MONTHS
OUR PROTECTION AGAINST
INFECTION AND PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE OVER 60 PROTECTION
AGAINST HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH DECREASES.
BOOSTER SHOT JUST LIKE ALL YOUR
TYPICAL VACCINES, WE GIVE THEM
VERY MANY MONTHS APART.
WE DON’T GIVE THEM ALL IN ONE
SEQUENCE.
A BOOSTER SHOT FOR COVID WOULD
BE VERY SIMILAR TO BOOSTER
SHOTS WE GET FOR OTHER VACCINES
AND REALLY HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
GIVE MANY, MANY YEARS OF
IMMUNITY.
SO IT IS NOT JUST THE NUMBER,
IT IS THE SPACING.
I’M VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE DATA
OUT OF ISRAEL AND PUBLISHED
THIS WEEKEND SHOWING THAT THE
THIRD SHOT IS HIGHLY PROTECTIVE
IN THOSE OVER 60 IN PARTICULAR.
>> Bill: IN ORDER TO GET THE
APPROVAL YOU NEED TIME TO MAKE
SURE IT WORKS, RIGHT?
JUST LIKE THE SIX MONTH PFIZER
VACCINE FOLLOWED BY A BOOSTER
PERHAPS IF NECESSARY.
BUT THERE ARE AMERICANS GETTING
THE VACCINE LAST DECEMBER.
SO THAT’S A FULL EIGHT, NINE
MONTHS AGO FROM TODAY.
SO AT WHAT POINT WOULD PFIZER
THEN UNDERSTAND AND KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT A BOOSTER WAS
NECESSARY?
CAN YOU FORECAST THAT?
>> SO PFIZER HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WAENG IMMUNITY.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
PUBLICATIONS OF WANING MANY
UNITY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE TIME THAT
GOES BY.
SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT MONTHS IS A
TIME WHEN IMMUNITY WANES AND
YOU HAVE TO WAIT THAT AMOUNT OF
TIME.
WHAT WE’RE SEEING RIGHT NOW NOT
ONLY WANING IMMUNITY BUT THE
VACCINE IS EFFECTIVE AGAINST
DELTA BUT NOT AS MUCH AS THE
OTHER VARIANTS AND PARENT
STRAIN.
WHAT WE’RE SEEING NOW IS
BECAUSE OF DIMINISHED
EFFECTIVENESS OF DELTA AND
WANING IMMUNITY AND GETTING THE
CASES.
I’M CERTAIN IT WILL BE
AUTHORIZED FOR AT LEAST PEOPLE
OVER 60 OR MAYBE OVER 50 WITHIN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> Dana: WE KNOW EFFICACY GOES
DOWN AFTER EIGHT MONTHS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
LASTING EFFECTS OF NATURAL
IMMUNITY?
>> SO NATURAL IMMUNITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THERE IS STILL NO
DATA TO SUGGEST THAT VACCINE
IMMUNITY IS BETTER THAN NATURAL
IMMUNITY.
I THINK BOTH ARE HIGHLY
PROTECTIVE.
WE DO KNOW, HOWEVER, EVEN IF
YOU ARE NATURALLY IMMUNE A DOSE
OF VACCINE CAN RAISE IT FURTHER.
I THINK IF YOU HAD PROOF OF
COVID INFECTION RIGHT NOW IT IS
STILL EQUIVALENT TO VACCINE
IMMUNITY.
EVEN THE CDC RECOGNIZES THAT IF
YOU ARE AN AMERICAN COMING BACK
TO THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU HAVE PROOF OF A PREVIOUS
COVID INFECTION YOU DON’T NEED
TO BE TESTED.
WHEN BUSINESSES REOPEN THEY
OUGHT TO CONSIDER NATURAL
IMMUNITY, VACCINE IMMUNITY OR
FREQUENT TESTING ALL TO GET YOU
BACK IN THE WORKPLACE.
>> Dana: I HAD ONE LAST QUICK
THING.
SOME HAVE SUGGESTED THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO GO AFTER BIG
PHARMA AND COMPLAIN ABOUT BIG
PHARMA AND THE PROFITS
SUGGESTING A BOOSTER IS A WAY
FOR THEM TO MAKE MORE MONEY.
HOW WOULD YOU REPLY TO THAT?
>> LOOK, I’M NOT GOING TO
DEFEND BIG PHARMA EXCEPT TO SAY
THEY CAME TO THE RESCUE WITH A
LOT OF GOVERNMENT SUPPORT.
THE DOSES ARE $20 A DOSE.
NOT VERY EXPENSIVE.
THE SCIENCE CLEARLY SAYS IT IS
NOT A PHARMA SCHEME, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO PROTECT
AMERICANS.
THE FIRST TWO DOSES AND NOW WE
SEE THE THIRD DOSE.
>> Bill: LAST POINT OUT OF THE
WHOLE BOOSTER THING.
YOU WILL HAVE SOME PEOPLE WHO
WILL RUN TO THEIR DOCTOR TO GET
THE BOOSTER SHOT.
SOME PEOPLE SAYING YOU TOLD ME
TO GET THE VACCINE, I GOT THE
VACCINE AND NOW I HAVE TO GO
BACK AGAIN?
FROM A MEDICAL STANDPOINT AND
MESSAGING STANDPOINT HOW DO YOU
COMMUNICATE THAT TO PEOPLE,
IT’S THE NEXT STEP YOU NEED TO
DO TO KEEP YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
SAFE?
>> I WOULD JUST ASK PEOPLE TO
CONSIDER WHEN THEY GET THEIR
CHILDREN VACCINATED, THEY DON’T
GET ALL THE VACCINES IN ONE
LITTLE BUNCH.
SAME THING FOR OTHER THINGS.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO GET IT
OVER TIME.
MONTHS SHOULD PASS AND YOUR
IMMUNE SYSTEM EVOLVES ITS
RESPONSE.
WHEN YOU GET THAT BOOST IT’S
LONG LASTING.
WHAT WE HEARD IN THE PANDEMIC
WE GOT EVERYBODY VACCINATED TO
SQUELCH THE STORM, THE FIRE,